cae otoniel uno de los narcotraficantes
más buscados de colombia el presidente
iván duque mostró la captura del líder
del clan del golfo como un gran logro de
su gobierno
este es el golpe más duro que se le ha
propiciado al narcotráfico en este siglo
en nuestro país y este golpe es
solamente comparable con la caída de
pablo escobar en los años 90 pero
antonio úsuga fue imputado por la
justicia estadounidense en 2009 enfrenta
un proceso de extradición para que
comparezca ante la corte del distrito
sur de nueva york este país ofrecía una
recompensa de 5 millones de dólares por
su captura usuga quien comenzó su vida
ilegal en la guerrilla izquierdista de
lepe él lideraba hasta su detención un
grupo paramilitar conocido como
autodefensas gaitanistas de colombia el
grupo según el gobierno se financia
principalmente con el tráfico de droga
la minería ilegal y la extorsión pero la
captura de otoniel no implica el fin de
la organización ni de na
pero hay cuatro personas que han sido de
su confianza que han ascendido digamos a
partir de que han dado de baja a otro de
los cabecillas entonces tenemos cuatro
posibilidades de que ellos hagan una
organización y sigan en la estructura o
muy posiblemente seguramente el clan del
golfo es acusado de ser uno de los
principales responsables de la peor ola
de violencia que atraviesa el país desde
2016 cuando el gobierno colombiano firmó
la paz con la guerrilla de las farc